[Music]
all right massive breaking news this
hour about the Clinton bought and paid
for fake news Russian propaganda dossier
that of course was used by the Obama
administration to obtain FISA warrants
to surveil members of the Trump campaign
and then the president-elect our own IDI
Henry is reporting that in two
closed-door meetings this week House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez that he told Republican lawmakers
that he has seen evidence so showing
clear abuse of government surveillance
programs by the FBI and Department of
Justice officials at Henry is also
reporting that Nunez told his colleagues
that he plans to share evidence of this
abuse with the entire house later this
month
now this is a major development but as
we've been saying there is so much more
information that needs to come out and
it will because I'm telling you this is
the beginning of a massive historic
scandal it's unfolding unlike anything
this country has ever seen before
this is going to reach the very highest
levels of your government including the
DOJ the FBI the Intel community Sarah
Carter tonight reporting and we have
confirmed this with our sources that as
soon as next week examples of systemic
FISA abuses will in fact be revealed any
unbiased so-called journalists well they
should be able to see this as the major
story it is worthy of further
investigation but as the media in this
country so abusively biased and so
anti-trump that they can no longer care
about simple basic fundamental truth our
Constitution our freedoms our liberties
does the media not care about any of
this the media as we have been pointing
out nightly is so bad at this point in
time in history and so radically left in
their ideology that in fact sadly truth
facts they don't get through to them the
only thing that seems to matter is
destroying and D legitimizing president
Trump that has been their only objective
for over a year and you see it happening
day after day hour after hour it's
pretty disgusting it's pathetic
it's a disservice it's disgraceful to
you the American people but it's why
we're gonna keep asking the tough
questions here on this program and we'll
keep getting information
that the American people all of you
deserve to know and also tonight the
president is a viscera ting FBI agent
Peter struck and his FBI lawyer mistress
Lisa Paige over there anti-trump text
messages now the president is telling
The Wall Street Journal quote a man is
tweeting to his lover that if she loses
will essentially go back to the will go
back to the insurance policy which is
they lose will go to Phase two and we'll
get this guy out of office I mean this
is the FBI we're talking about I think
that is you know that is treason see
that's treason right there and the
president added that's a treasonous act
what he tweeted to his lover is
treasonous now here's the insurance
policy text message President Trump is
referring to struck writing his mistress
I want to believe the path you threw her
out for consideration in Andy's office
that there's no way he gets elected but
I'm afraid we can't take that risk
it's like an insurance policy in the
unlikely event you die before you're 40
now we here at Fox News and on this show
we believe we haven't confirmed yet the
Andy mentioned in that text is the
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe now
that message it's only the beginning of
this massive scandal stay with us here
it gets complicated
now strucken page also called trump an
idiot alone some human and said f trump
and congressional investigators they're
working to determine if these Trump
hating FBI lovers were leaking
information about the Russia
investigation of the press after a new
round of their text messages were
released by the way there's about 9,000
more to go and struck also set in on
Hillary Clinton's FBI interview for the
email investigation after he and James
Comey exonerated her or began writing
the exoneration letter before the
investigation and it was struck that
signed the original documents taking off
the Russia investigation
this guy's corrupt tentacles touch
seemingly everything also in general
Flynn now what struck is done here it is
crooked it is scandalous and that even
former Clinton strategist mark Penn is
saying he should be fired here's what
Penn said on the Fox Business Network
take a look I think that tweet is one of
the most damaging things I've ever
seen from someone in the government at
every level I don't understand how he's
still employed by the FBI I don't
understand how a criminal investigation
hasn't been opened to all of this to me
that is hugely damaging to confidence in
the FBI these two folks were having an
affair
using official government channels for
their personal communications that alone
would have made them a security threat
kind of refreshing I was a Democrat
being honest for once now there are
reportedly 10,000 total messages between
struck and page we've only gotten a
fraction of them that scandal is only
going to get bigger now in addition to
his comments about Peter struck two The
Wall Street Journal President Trump is
also taking aim at congressman Adam
Schiff the ranking Democrat on the House
in tell you left meetings where people
are being interviewed and then all of a
sudden they say a story about what's
going on inside the meetings well it's
probably illegal what he's doing but the
Democrats well they know it's a hoax an
excuse for them having lost the election
now while it's unclear if Schiff has
been leaking we know for a fact that
another top ranking Democrat has been
leaking president Trump is continuing to
slam who he's now calling sneaky Senator
Dianne Feinstein because she
unilaterally released the fusion GPS
testimony before Congress and Trump
tweeted Democrat Dianne Feinstein should
never have released secret committee
testimony to the public without
authorization
very disrespectful to committee members
and possibly illegal as she blamed her
poor decision by the way and the fact
that she had a cold a bet in school the
dog ate her homework and what
Feinstein's actions are threatening to
disrupt the Senate's investigation
releasing the transcript actually
provided some very revealing information
about fusion GPS and their founder Glenn
Simpson Simpson actually testified he
never even bothered to verify with the
former British spy Christopher Steele
had actually put in the Russian source
phony dossier he also admitted that he
was against Trump during the election so
clearly Simpson was more than happy to
take over ten million dollars from
Hillary Clinton and the DNC that she's
running and put this dossier together
that they then tried to use to influence
the American people Oh Russian
propaganda to influence an election
bought and paid for by Hillary and then
a FISA warrant and finally tonight
Judicial Watch the scoring another major
legal victory a federal judge is now
ordering the State Department to ramp up
the release of Hillary Clinton's email
from our time as Secretary of State and
according to Judicial Watch the FBI
discovered 72,000 pages of documents
last year that Clinton either tried to
delete or did not disclose you cannot
make this stuff up if I wrote the most
obscene spy novel you couldn't make this
up